welcome back Leslie Jones is with
us so Leslie's new Memoir is called
Leslie bleeping Jones in the book
bleeping would have been funny to go
with too by the way uh Leslie recounts a
lot of great moments from her life some
of them funny and some of them scary so
in honor of that it's time for a funny
and scary round of what's creeping up on
me
Oh's creeping
[Music]
up is she doing like I sang all my break
was creeping up on
me hey left all right are you good at
games very and I'm very competitive
remember the last time we was here oh my
God we're going to have such a good time
okay no I never cheat I never cheat
that's a lie from Satan's mouth all
right here's how it works Leslie will
start with her back to the screen I'm
going to give her clues about what's
creeping up behind her without saying
the name of the thing then we're going
to switch sides and Leslie will give me
clues it's not too hard yeah we can can
pass if it is too hard though um and if
we can correctly guess 10 things total
and two rounds uh one each then the
audience will win a prize so hopefully
we don't fail you if you can't oh well
all right let's get into position back
there you're over there on that okay I'm
right here okay and I am about to kill
it so I so I got to act out the stuff no
no no I'm seeing this time and you're
guessing what I'm doing okay
okay okay okay okay are you ready okay
go uh lot of legs on oh wait crawling on
the ground lot of legs lot of legs
alligator no like a tiny little worm
like thing cinnamon
yep um oh uh Johnny Five alive do you
know that movie uh no that's
why um okay it's a this is a dance this
is a dance robot okay oh and it's
a robot knif no like a like what am I
Robot kill K road kill kill killer road
kill no it's like a robot kill get back
kill robot killer
robot this a scary movie you know it's
coming up out of the the water it's a
zombie like it's a it's like a it's like
a this is really hard M A mum a it's a
it's a it's a zombie it's a mummy it's
it's a
kraken what am I doing right now I am
girl you faing very bad at this
day
[Applause]
wait no okay so if you were on a boat
out at I wouldn't be on a
boat we're switching H you got to get a
bunched that was hard okay first of all
my short why was it so hard my short is
short so if you see my butt just gone
with you life go on with it what is this
that is failing yes you fail so bad
talking about what you doing you fell
badly at this I did okay so you're going
to give the clues now
so yes good luck if they give you easy
ones I
swear child what they do now and they
just be causing so many accidents when
they do this men
yeah
okay is something kiding I love men it's
okay okay what are what what are the the
children when they get when they get all
right but ding yes but what is the worst
thing they do wreck okay but but why do
they wreck because they're on their
phone and they're doing what they're
they're not paying
attention Tex
it oh okay oh okay okay not not a lion
but a a panther okay
no uh lions and blank oh my oh Tigers
yes
okay oh hell no oh oh man come on man
come on oh man in every White movie in a
house every White movie every little
white girl that's in a scary movie got
one she does something stupid yeah but
she always got one of these though she
always got the scariest one of these
doll
right but
[Applause]
okay
it's in the desert and you don't want to
run into it scorpion no no that his
friend his homeboy his homeboy a snake
but not not a snake it has a whole bunch
of legs has a whole bunch of legs in the
desert and the okay it's a it's a and
it's the it's the it's the worst thing
you ever would want to happen to you no
no no it's not it's got eight legs it's
a spider yeah but what kind though the
scarest
girl it's hard to get it out of here too
that's that was really hard we didn't
make it time they did that on purpose we
didn't make it in time what you mean I
make it on time they still should get
that it's not because of us all
right just because we stock does not
mean you don't get something yes yes you
still win we just lose we lose everybody
the MAA triflex hx1 Pro is the
top-of-the line german-made cordless
stick vacuum featuring a patented
threein one design for maximum
flexibility three cleaning
configurations
yes it's the perfect replacement for any
ported upright vacuum and even has heil
filtration this baby is worth $900 and
everyone in the honors is going on with
one we'll be right back
[Applause]
[Music]
CER thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home